the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
hi everyone today we're going to be
doing trip prep and review and so the
first part of trip prep this would work
better if I were actually projecting
wouldn't it so trip prep and review and
the first thing we're going to do is
presentation so each team has like 15
minutes to present and then five to ten
minutes of questions and then we'll go
through a review of a few things that
got missed or badly presented previously
and then going over trip prep and then
there will be a little bit of time for
you guys to work in teams and a few
critical things I also need to talk to
every single person who's traveling just
one-on-one it's a deal of requirement so
we'll do that yeah are there any
questions before we start with
presentations okay cool so awesome
Phoenix if you guys want to go first
that would be awesome alright so we're
also Phoenix um I'm Carter I'm close I'm
roster Breanna and our team mentors can
so ASA Phoenix is a small Nicaraguan NGO
or based in two areas el revoir what's
this oh and there are four parts that
we're looking at right now one of them
is the oj sealer which goes it might be
aware of the next would be the millet
thresher the washing machine and the bow
digester so we're not handed off to us
so the oj sealer is a project of Steel a
project previously and we're going to
delivery so sorry but it was a previous
it's not our project so don't want to
take credit for it but we're delivering
it to the community down there and the
purpose is to be able to seal orange
juice so that they can sell it at a
later date when emerges during the
harvest and oranges are just so
plentiful that the cost really isn't
worth selling so if they can bag the
juice and it's Ella later they'll be
able to make money from their harvest so
how it works is you have it's kind of
like the sealers we use them that and
you bring down this lever here and then
you can latch it there's a latch that
secures it in place and that's like a
safety feature and also ensures a good
connection between the metal and the
plastic so that you could get a good
seal and also you can't just kind of
Joel to or lift it up accidentally then
you end up with a mess and possibly an
injury so there's a latch there's
there's a switch that you press and then
it heats for 10 seconds you can adjust
that time we'll have to I guess optimize
that time it's it's 10 seconds now from
understand it's all your tray so we
might adjust that time and there's an
LED that lights up while the rod is
heating so that the user knows that it
is hot and not to undo the latch and
open the rod so this project and 10
second opinion that this the metal is
used as heats up very quickly and also
cools off very quickly so in that 10
seconds you allow after that 10 seconds
over you allow like five seconds of
cooling and then you can open the the
leverage safely so we're going to go
down and implement the project and some
of the instructions that will have to
give kind of how to handle the plastic
waste that they have because they're
most likely not accustomed to having the
sheets of plastic and what
make sure they understand the
consequences of littering in the
environment and then also exploring the
operations
so when we were first getting the groups
and the projects and stuff there is
mention of a feed chopper well after
talking about the Phoenix it turns out
they're actually interested in is a
different part of harvest processing is
a threshing their millet crop that means
is taking the bubble seeds or within the
pic home flora its little stocks on the
big one and removing all the seeds from
it separating the Pacific nations that
can so these are a couple different
designs that have been built by various
groups they're both you can't see the
actual mechanism is doing the thrashing
and vote in either of them but it's that
basically they've got like little spikes
on I think this one has two drums inside
each other with little spikes that are
knocking the seeds out and this one
they've taken the tire off the wheel and
using all the spokes sticking out of the
frame of the wheel to break it off we
didn't since we only found out what the
project was for a recently we haven't
done much thinking about our own designs
this stuff we're wondering if these are
kind of capacity so things were mainly
on the trip we're going to be like
getting information about the process
not something we're familiar with you
know what you need to do it fresh the
militant their harvest is 4,000 pounds
we need to know how much that actually
is
to give you an idea of how much we need
to instruction at a time and then there
are different varieties we need to know
what variety they're using which will
help determine with the appropriate
methods threshing it is how long they
need to do it and they're currently
doing it by hand and how efficient is
this there were discussion about moving
the machine between different
communities and so whether the different
communities are harvesting at the same
time or not is going to affect how fast
it needs to work is if everyone's
harvesting at the same time that more
people that need to get their harvests
done within a smaller map time but
somebody a few miles aways lower
elevation and has the harvest slightly
earlier that gives us more times right
so the preliminary expects they're
currently taking four days to touch the
harvest we could get that down to eight
hours all of these I'm not going to go
through and read them all because
they're mostly very arbitrary at this
point and for this project it's going to
be a lot of information gathering
okay um so the next project we wanted to
look at was a washing machine
interestingly enough we were kind of so
gung hope for this that we kind of
looked through and did the most planning
and it turns out that also Phoenix said
no we'd rather have you focus on this so
you know that's part of the planning
process but in any case oh shoot which
are not going through anyway so there's
a some key things we want to keep in
mind for the washing machine are the
preservation of water there might not be
that much water to use in this community
also Phoenix really also wants to
utilize the gray water to do something
useful rather than this is dumping it we
also have a couple different variables
to consider so do lab has done a lot of
work with washing machines in the past
this is one of the designs safe to come
up with Benji's not here right now but
he also showed us a one or one that he
did for Dee lab of design that was a
similar design like this so we kind of
took this and ran with it the yes so
this is basically the same idea except
using direct drive from a bicycle that
can be detached and still used to the
bicycle instead of a bicycle it's kind
of gutted for parts and mounted directly
to the thing the kind of key variable
we'd like to test here is whether do
side your top loading that kind of
depends how efficient and easy it is to
load we'd also like to kind of alter and
play with the inner drum design we make
it out of rope shun you get a chicken
wire should we we thinking for a while
of doing kind of nylon bags that would
be pin in place that would kind of spin
and be their own rotors and then also
kind of draining message so again we can
preserve as much gray water as we can
sorry I had a spec sheet and apparently
my openoffice format random
but their peril intimate and then the
product of ASA Phoenix are also greatest
want us to focus on is the biodata sure
so what this is is basically I wanted us
to find a way to efficiently mix up the
slough and based off their current
concrete plastic bag method so here are
spec sheets basically wanted to be hand
powered or bicycle power the main
requirement being there's no electricity
needed we need something that stays in
the same scale that they already have
four to ten cubic meters and then after
one use they want to produce about one
cubic meter of biogas and should take
about 23 hours to complete those are the
main specs that they wanted us to
achieve upon further discussion with
also Phoenix they showed us that this is
their current design oh and they want us
to actually not focus on a method of
mixing the sloop but actually finding
way our method to determine overflow
improve their current process and find a
way to gauge how much fog after
producing at any given time so right now
what's happening is you can see the
positive tags in the background and
biogas is delivered through this tube
from right to left and as there's
overflow it goes down this pipe and
bulbs in the water so if any user where
to see bubbles throughout the water they
would know that there is being usage
there's being overflow usage that being
said you don't know how much is in the
tubes until it's too much this can only
determine whether it's over flooring or
not and can only be told you can only
tell that if you're there and see the
bubbles so if you're asleep and it
starts bubbling you will notice have is
happening and so they want to find a new
method to determine how much bad has to
be produced so we change the whole
project in regards to distance of a
mixer and started looking at the sort of
manometer pressure gauge system with how
to determine how much gas in there so
we're thinking about throwing a
basically just a rubber tube having a
fixed diameter
circular objects such as a soda can
plastic bottle something of a fixed
diameter that's common there and we
would wrap the plastic tubing around it
and fill it up with water and we measure
make sure the water levels are even and
then we would release the valve and so
we can see the pressure difference
between the water and that head losses
or that had differences how much
pressure there is inside oh and then
we'll have more King saying like you
know it's this much had difference than
there will be you know blank Mountain
pressure which means no point 6 cubic
meters of biogas and then every day they
can check out how much gas there is
because the pressure difference then
once I hit a certain head loss
difference then they will know they're
reaching reaching their overflow
capacity this will help them determine
how much they have and how much they can
use so let's see if they wanted to use
some and they weren't full they wouldn't
want to try to use you know 25 cubic
meters of the only appoint one so this
is the biodigester and some key
activities also basically just quick
summary of our our projects the oj
sealer yeah so this outlines kind of
what huge projects going to accomplish
while we're down there so we're going to
deliver the oj sealer explain its uses
and benefits to the community
and then for the possibility
we can't observe the shelling process or
inquire into it if it's not an
appropriate time to observe it and
for the washing machine will determine
how much research will be useful look at
how they wash their clothes now and just
like how we can on my side with partners
for the biodigester we want to go there
see the their current method and see how
we can implement our process that you
can help teach them our preliminary
concept and get feedback from them and
overall just kind of objectives for our
trip we also want to explore a typical
Nicaraguan a hardware store to see like
if we were to give them a design for a
project what materials they have
available like at hand then also
developed the relationships with the
community partners down there so you can
continue working as a deal a program
with them and then take all necessary
measurements that might be helpful
really do each individual project and
finally we like to give the cauldrons to
Amy me can deal out of MIT and I'll
spades any questions
so one is did you get the sealer working
we're able to connect it to a power
supply yeah you should do that before
you leave to make sure it's still
working preferably real soon so that's
not working you can troubleshoot it and
you might also want to drill into that
plastic box you can make the timing
adjustment I know that the timer was set
for 10 seconds because what the plastic
bags that this ruthless using that got
them consistent good sealing even with
like orange juice flopped over or in the
ceiling zone but we don't know what bags
will be used by us to Phoenix so that's
why you want to be able to adjust it but
yeah it's pretty critical that you don't
bring it and then be like oh it doesn't
work it could be good to know why it
doesn't work at least so good to know
when you before you leave for the millet
thresher I don't know if you were
referred to Donna Cohen at Hampshire
College but she's been working on pearl
millet threshing a lot and so she might
be a good resource both in terms of
ideas as well as I know she's been
trying to grow pearl millet out there
and so if you do end up working on this
project one of your challenges will be
not having access to the thing you're
actually trying to work on because you
can't bring it back from Nicaragua
without going through the u.s.
agricultural stuff and that's going to
take longer than the rest of semester
probably to get through so finding out
from her if she is in fact growing and
if she does have a supply would be
pretty useful to know if it's the
project's going to be viable for and
then I liked your list of sort of
universal things I do have some lists of
products available in general Nicaraguan
hardware stores that I can send you to
and then but I definitely visit one and
get a sense yourself I would also
encourage you to
to identify other projects that they
might be interested in either for this
year or for future years it's nice to
just have a ongoing list and then
finally with the millet beyond just
getting information if they've got if
it's being harvested now if they have
some doing some experiments to really
understand what sort of operations
thresh successfully as opposed to not
and then also just documenting as much
as possible about their particular
millet because they're all are a lot of
different varieties and so if they don't
work with pearl millet but something
else or Donna has a different version of
promo and it's be good to know what the
differences are so
cool and then you guys were thinking
about trying to build the biodigester
sensor right so do you have your
materials list for that prepared and you
know what you're bringing from here what
they can get there okay awesome thanks
so hi everyone my name is what we are a
group of Phoenix my name is Jessica
please debian sid one and kurt is here
in spirit with us all the way from costa
uh-huh he's doing some field work before
it um uh so in our presentation today we
decided that part of our project which
will learn about is charcoal cookers and
we're gonna have to teach the community
and how to teaching how to work with
this so we're going to be presenting in
front of this community and we're not
going to have the PowerPoint or anything
to help us with the presentation so we
tried to make this a little demo and see
how we can do that um to this crowd so
we're not going to speak in spanish
today but we are going to try to let go
of PowerPoint presentations day um it's
a little bit about our trip so in
today's presentation up with you a
little bit about our trip and we'll walk
you through each of our projects our
final sketches that we have what we're
working on right now and what are some
finals coca nations that we want to do
before we head out there next week and
and i'll just start with some little bit
of background so we'll be visiting
Oakland um which is like 20 minutes now
we'll be visiting beautiful Phoenix
which is like 20 minutes outside of
Oakland which is north of nagata mana
was which is map which is me that I was
capital um and we're going to be
basically working with a group called
group of feet excuse me with a group of
women called the solar women of de todo
god man total alpha and they are again a
group of around 20 25 women that are
interested in solar solar design solar
they design their own solar cooker and
you know a little bit about
background information in our trip we're
going to try to evaluate our main
objectives are to evaluate the existing
products and brainstorm ways to improve
so working with what they have on site
we've already sent them of the materials
list of what they should prepare for us
stuff to do the charcoal burns and stuff
to just see what they have on site to
work with and finally we'll send them
and while we're there we'll show them
what we have in mind and we'll try to
sort of meet in the middle from what
what they want and what we have in mind
and make that happen when we come back
so first we'll start with charcoal
projects so there's actually two parts
to the turbo project the first is that
we're going to be doing a truck over at
them they've actually been taught how to
do this before they still have the
materials from last time so mostly we're
just going to sort of like refresh their
memories so I think a lot of what we're
going to do is the teaching is instead
of you know doing everything ourselves
we're mostly going to kind of stand back
and watch what they already know how to
do and then kind of like be like oh it
might work a little bit better if you do
it this way then show that maybe a
little improvement that they can do so
it's kind of just making sure that what
they're doing now is correct and trying
to prove it a little bit but the other
thing we're doing is working with the
charcoal stove if you remember when you
saw projects from previous deal apps
there was this sheet metal stove that
was all what pieces I was cut up and
then folded into this panel and
hexagonal shape with like a slightly
open up top so we're going to be trying
to either improve that stove or come up
with a new one depending on their needs
when we go there so we had some ideas
for improving that one a basic one was
just to add insulation so if you add
play around the base of it kind of like
these stoves that we saw the other day
then that might help a solution a lot
and we talked to a group of Phoenix and
they actually have a van in the town who
has a kiln and they said we can use it
as long as we tell them what you want to
use it so we're planning on that take
advantage of that and just actually
trying not what we're there put like
putting whatever play materials that
they have easily available and making it
and then seeing if that improves its
you know how quickly you can cook with
it we're also going to try some other
things like adding kind of like using
chicken wire some other easily available
material on top of that so that they can
kind of like have not really grilled but
just like a surface on top of the stove
on which they can put things so it's
more adjustable for sizes of fans we
also might need to improve airflow but
it kind of depends on which pants by
using it with because it's long as like
they're pans aren't perfectly fitting
then it has enough airflow but if we
need more we can either if we're using
like if we're using the the clay we can
kind of lift it up a little bit but how
to have some holes underneath so that it
can come up from beneath and then the
air can kind of like keep the fire going
or the charcoal burning or we could just
kind of make the Z design a little bit
looser because it's held together right
now by a string around the outside of
the top and if you sort of loosen that
string a little bit it actually proof is
like might open up holes a little bit in
the design to let more air flow through
but we also could design a new stove um
well yes a real sort of campus and a
convenient Stoke um from what we've seen
that what actually works is the stove
that we had last in the complete place
though
yeah well miss our last 10,000 if
located close to a middle and handle
sorting of because we we have a kid over
there because complete the scientists up
with a woman and some of the improvement
we were thinking about what any handles
of the easy to carry in a different
material I'm adding a door also had to
increase the air flow and I'm so adding
a trace you can pull the truck go in and
out as much as you want out of this dope
and me so we just saw what were their
rosters going to look with the woman my
water is that they actually cook the
heat they need and where it is a dick
cook so it needs more shelter allegedly
from the wind how how much time do they
actually have the producer to make the
charcoal half yeah have my constant they
have and how easy it is to actually
place the stove's where they are living
so its release or carrier put down or if
they need to move it I'm not a kilometer
every day and yes we special cooking
time and they are available sizes and
shapes of
okay yeah so the next thing we worked on
is so the next thing we worked on is
like the solar cooker project now
basically we approached it like three
ways we talked about the existing
research that was already done we we
looked into what they have currently we
looked into the product specifications
and we looked into the question that we
had for them as far as the literature
goes um so we looked into like what
types of solar cooker designs like
predominantly exist right now and
they're basically like three types of
designs you have two curved
concentrators which are basically is
like you have your cooker here and you
have some kind of parabolic mirror which
reflects sunlight of the cooker and
they're curved concentrators because the
parabola murders occur the second type
is like a heat box which is basically
just a box which is the greenhouse
effect so you have like the Sun sunlight
hitting the box and the box retain
retaining a lot of heat and then the
third type is your panel to learn cooker
which is basically like a box with like
a hinged ferrer on it where you have
sunlight hitting the mirror and then the
am again reflected onto the box so those
are the three types that predominantly
exist when you really look into what
they have currently with them there they
basically use a hybrid between like the
box the heat box here and the panel
heater where there were some presents do
have our panels but then they also use
reflective surfaces inside to keep it
more um so
a group of columbia university has been
working with us a little bit of total
bubba to develop but they currently have
no and it has inside this box kind of
solar cooker the one thing we really
really want to focus on the way yet
there is out figure out why it's so
expensive to manufacture the women
really pride themselves in like being
able to make this cooker on their own
but so we want to see how we can work
with them like what they like about the
hooker and specifically what materials
make it so expensive to make so we kind
of came up with a new i don't decide
that we might want to improve upon and
it's kind of the same but i think to
really move forward with this we really
need to figure out the materials that
are available to us
yelling yeah i just wanted to really fix
it so for the designs basically like we
wanted to do two different types of
designs one was like where we were
trying to improve what they have
currently and one was like we were we
wanted to design something new and so
basically we came up with two things so
this is an improvement and then we
bypassed around later but this is an
improvement I think what we think is an
improvement on their current design we
think in my produce material costs and
improve efficiency this design is kind
of like a mixture between the curve
concentrator and the heat box
essentially like this was trying to make
like a pressure cooker we weren't sure
there's a need for that so so she wanted
for questions for wondering like how
much food actually cooked using pressure
cookers but we did we did see any
literature about them using a
genetically and we were wondering if it
was possibly then you use so that those
are the basic to decide to talk about it
which expects you so some of my respects
our it needs to definitely retain you to
think about will consider like different
types of insulation it has to be able to
reach high temperatures whether they
need to be cooking different kinds of
or just boiling water it also has to be
able to withstand different weather
conditions if it's going to be sitting
outside because it's a smaller quicker
the climate in Nicaragua is kind of
humid and it does run along so that's
really important needs to be affordable
which we've already mentioned before and
easy to manufacture preferably yeah okay
we actually came up with like a bunch of
them but these were we thought most
important another thing that like could
play a role is how is technically like
pleasing it is because like we did come
across that our sugar they refuse to use
certain focus because they didn't like
the way if you look so that's a very
important part also which that's pretty
much show we're working on right and so
last but not least is the solar cell
phone charger and i'll be speaking on
behalf of me and kirk for this one um so
two key find you that we hadn't looked
in our literature research we're just a
comment that solar is the most flexible
and efficient of off-grid chargers and
we thought we were like yeah thumbs up
and they gave the rule of thumb that
about 60 minutes of charging would mean
ten minutes of talking on the phone now
the specifications of what kind of
panels you're using and whatever or not
all that can be optimized so that led it
that led us one of our design
considerations which is on in this
schematic basically a communal charger
so just having instead of one small
solar panel enough to charge one cell
phone at a time having a big like sort
of communal charging station but of
course that requires a field work of
being there for this weekend realizing
whether these people can actually work
together whether there's going to be
the risk of having your charger stolen
or having your cell phone batteries so
when was being charged or whether you
can have some kind of like a system
where you leave something that's yours
and that's it get stolen while you take
the battery so seeing how that works
with the different kinds of batteries
that they're using in their solar cell
in their cell phones are and so one idea
that also stems from that is having a
sort of like port that that's adaptable
to different kinds of cell phone
chargers because if they change the cell
phone then you're not going to throw
away the whole charging station so
that's some of the ideas that came from
that and another thing we were thinking
about was a design consideration that
they're going to be using their cell
phone cell phones on the fields um a lot
of time they'll leave home they'll go
work on the fields they'll go look for
food whatever it is and they'll need and
the Heather cell phones on them for a
long time so um if they ever have it
with them for longer than needed they
won't be able to let come home and
discharge it or plug in their charger
that they having a pocket into a wall
outlet right and realistic so one thing
we thought is like a mobile charger um
one technology that is a little advanced
I think for our for our skills right now
is um it's a layer of solar cells that's
integrated below the LCD screens of the
iphones but we thought that something to
that effect where the where the women
could carry it around with them and the
idea of the solar cell phone charger for
the iphone is that you can carry it in
your pocket with the LCD screen towards
the outside and the Rays just hit and
it's charging as you walk around kind of
thing so we thought that'd be a really
nice idea we could kind of like velcro
pouch make like some kind of velcro
pouch for the for the men and women that
are carrying around and then it's like
charged as they go or something so a
little more reliable of the technology
but we that takes a little more research
and if they even need that kind of
consideration so um so some of the
project specifications that we are
keeping in mind are the ones that i just
mentioned on the idea of maybe having a
charger that's not powered by solar
radiation i'm having different types of
phones and weather so instead of having
different kinds of phones and needing to
have the final connections to the phone
like what we usually use just taking out
the battery and seeing how that can fit
into the adaptable ports that i know
that i mentioned earlier and i'm being
able to charge your phone say at night
usually come home and we like to charge
your phone while we're sleeping wake up
in the morning pick it up and go um if
it's a solar cell if it's a solar
charger you wouldn't need the sunlight
so that's the little trade-off but would
be working with a kind of energy storage
in the solar panel it will be integrated
so you can charge it at night and use it
when you need to and finally of course
is always the risk of like with all of
our other projects of theft we are going
to be there this week also is next week
also assessing like if you leave
yourself solar panel on the roof is
there even a roof first of all if you
leave it on the roof can somebody feel
it you leave it on the roof is it going
to be damaged this is something you want
to be able to take in and now what if we
just set up a system where we have
somebody like a security guard for this
charging station and then maybe that's
just people are willing to pitch in if
you have a more efficient charging
mechanism with somebody you know
guarding the solar panels or something
so lots of little things that we've been
thinking about and I guess finally out
start the what we're going to do between
now and before we go of in these in this
past like us one week we've basically
divvied up the work so we become a
little experts in our little project but
what one thing that we definitely want
to do is that kind of read up on each
other's backgrounds all the literature
although you know cut each other up to
speed on every project one thing that
Amelia would
trip leader suggested is that we do
something back again below chemical
conditions maybe take that with us have
that on hand because that's one of the
technical skills that are valuable right
that's why we're there um and so just to
keep those numbers in minds and we've
had some correspondence with our
community partners and one of the things
in Astra and those were they provide was
was there going to be an opportunity for
us to cook with the families and I think
that'll be a really good experience and
she said there will be of course but
that would be a really good experience
because I will just help us like
strengthen our relationships with the
community and also I think the question
that we want to know for the slow
cookers is are they using the current
some quick room now and what are the
benefits of them using their like their
wood charcoal methods or however they're
cooking dominantly now versus using
yeah like it should give us a really
good opportunity both to the charcoal
aspect at Minnesota grass but just see
what they need to cook how often they
cook how long it takes right now you
know are the cooking indoors or outdoors
just like everything and so if we cook
with them it'll go strengthen the bond
but also answer all those questions
and that's us thoughts you might be
wanting to bring a thermometer and or
thermocouple data logger with you for
doing some of your stove measurements
with the data logger ah there's a book
on the G Co stove which is the stove
with the ceramic in it that explains
pretty clearly how to construct it as
well as the specifications for the
ceramic because different only certain
types of clay work for a G Co and
provide good insulation and I don't know
what will be a bit available in
Nicaragua it's rather different yes a
continent in Africa so I don't know how
that will compare I know some feedback
that I've heard on the stoves is just a
different height and or size that the
original design was designed to go
inside their existing wood stoves and a
lot of women preferred for it to be
freestanding so that would be another
area of investigation for the cell phone
charger I think definitely investigating
whether individual chargers or a shared
charger is preferable and sort of
figuring that out it's hard to say at
this point what people would actually
want and so really spending the time
asking the questions to learn that and
also phone usage like you just mentioned
you know like standard stuff is that I
you know most of us probably charge our
phones overnight and then use them
during the day is that what their usage
looks like and is that their ideal
scenario or is charging during the day
and using it during the night preferable
like that there's no telling without
asking those questions and I think
Amelia suggestion of running through
those estimations and
back-of-the-envelope calculations that
you have them on hand to modify and
adapt while you're in the field is a
great one for actually for every team so
question on that there's some mention in
like our syllabus or something about
having a journal the uragan that deal I
would provide from us is that I we're
going to get those soon or because then
we could put our calculations in that or
should we are we not going to get those
order ah yeah so I'm I would I will find
we don't know so sure um just to clarify
so last year we did give out journals
and a lot of the dlab trips gave them
out and found that most students didn't
use them and prefer to have their own
notebook that was the form factor that
they preferred the most like you know
it's hard to make a notebook that works
for everyone which is why when you go to
staples or wherever there's like twelve
thousand notebooks so so what's been
proposed is that that your trip leader
has the notebook that's like the
standard one that d-lab makes you guys
will get subsections of that notebook
just as like a pamphlet or you know
stapled documents that just has like the
emergency information and some Spanish
and things like that in it and that
you'll bring each one of you bring your
own notebook if you are like no I really
want the D lab notebook I think we could
do that by Friday so let me know there's
a list of things you need to let me know
by the end of class today that I'll be
talking about so if you could add that
to the list if you do want to note book
that would be good and otherwise you can
bring your own and then just start
populating it now any other question
yeah did anything jump out at you guys
any ideas that you might have had
you may see that portable light
thank you no
but it
what's
cells and you can put it on what they've
done is they make bad and then they just
open it up it comes a light
I don't
that's a great idea it's flexible solar
cells portable yes it's like a
it's like super thing
there are flexible ourselves I thought
about that and I thought it was the
professor had mentioned that he was
researching that so it's like oh that's
not out yet no no actually I should look
up um I don't think this is the ocean
for flexible ones they they just have
small ones that then because the this
problem with the flexible one does their
efficiency is lower but they are great
so and then the only other thing to
think about if you're going to do
wearables is thinking about where you're
actually going to get direct sunlight
because our people outside enough and
you know if the idea of putting the
iphone charger on your pocket concerns
me from how much direct sunlight are you
going to get because if you recall that
you need to be perpendicular to your
panel and so sunlight tends not to be
perpendicular to human body so so yeah
so just thinking about that that's one
of the challenges with wearable solar
panels is making sure they're actually
in the Sun enough I thought that uh one
consideration i'd be like you were
studying this with the water the first
lab we did of carrying water right um if
they're actually making long trips
that's a pretty good time to just if
they're carrying on their backs became
the load on the back then Mike put
something cousin trailer on or something
and put the solar panel on top and then
yeah so yeah so I think it's
investigating what is actually happening
what are people actually doing and you
will find rooms there so you don't need
to worry about lack of roofs really fun
one you mentioned you weren't sure if
there would be roofs and people do have
through roofs yeah okay they do so
that's us well thanks
alright so I'm whereas across our I'm
Ben Z Amelia agent G so I haven't had
like much communication with a
suppressor yet is there a new community
partner in El Salvador so some of our
projects are kind of just our ideas and
what we would like to see or would like
to implement it's not necessarily what
we're actually that projects that were
actually gonna be working on while we're
down there we know there would
definitely be doing a charcoal burn but
other than that kind of up in the air
but I so froze our have a kind of focus
on rural areas and needy communities so
we're thinking that we're going to be in
rural area selector so we aren't totally
sure about the exact projects of we're
looking at ventilation for cooking the
houses charcoal stoves and lighting
improvements so like with for instance
with lighting improvements we don't know
what kind of looks that have since are
questions that we need to ask
so just to introduce some of the things
we looked at we just created a library
with like an image and then just key
phrases of what these things are and as
Ben Z said I think most of our time
there would actually be asking questions
we've come up with a lot of questions
just to really get to know what people
need and then work with them as opposed
to come up with some idea and just try
to close it but so in terms of the
ventilation or using stoves that make a
lot less smoke we looked at for example
the first image is that a solar chimney
which is a hollow wall that's built into
the space that pushes the hot air out
and cool air comes from the other side
of the house so I guess simple spatial
techniques that can create more air flow
depending on where the stove is we can
get a lot of the smoke out of the house
and some of the stoves we looked at or
the AC stove is one of the first ones
and it's clay a lot of them were very
similar and some of them were mentioned
from previous groups what but clay stove
that usually has an opening on the
bottom and that old piece on top the
clay is used for a little bit more
insulation than just a sheet sheet metal
and this it's made with ceramic or mud
and it's something that could be or is
made by women and they could be sold for
profit a couple of the solar cookers are
another idea and they were mentioned
before I was with the two that I looked
at one of was actually an MIT project
and
years ago I think and so both of them
use reflective surfaces to create to get
the light and focus it onto a surface to
heat up the echo Tina is and then the
other on the onion stove they're pretty
similar their cast cement or concrete
they similar to the one of the UK's see
above was that they have an opening on
the on the bottom and metal plate on top
that's used to heat the food they
produce a lot less smoke and because of
the insulation the fuel is actually
reduced by about sixty percent which is
great the one on the bottom is a
improved three-stone fire stove and all
it is is building it was a series of
steps used to
to show how you can actually build a
stove with clay and using the bricks and
it's it's not portable it's going to be
built in use where where you want it but
it has it has an opening on top and that
usually a hole on the bottom for airflow
and to feed the fuel some of the the
charcoal stoves that we looked at and
we've talked about these pacheco this
other one below is very similar designed
just a little different and one this one
uses clay and it has the holes and the
one on the bottom is again something
that we saw that has you can control the
airflow by the different openings the
door openings are openings on the bottom
or on the side so depending on how much
I guess both which we needed to heat up
and how much air we want to let in terms
of the lighting this first project was
actually the portable light that I
mentioned and what they do is they they
make a bag and they put these flexible
solar cells on it so that the women when
they carry it charges in it
open it up it uses these reflective and
diffused surfaces it actually to make
the most use out of the light source
that they use and it's usually used for
studying has enough light to study at
night some of the other light sources we
looked at were solar lights mostly
whether portable or stationary something
that can be charged during the day use
at night and they come in so many
different
flashlights these bottom was you can
hang from the ceiling you can carry
anywhere with you so it's there all the
way common that they use a solar panel
to charge and the actual place sources
it's different but actually the idea
that the information that we know about
the communities is that they actually do
have access to the grid but they have
very few light bulbs or because they
don't have that much power out of it
we're not really sure yet so in terms of
looking at precedents we weren't really
sure what these things could be but we
have some ideas
as little light as they have in order to
brighten up the space as much as
and these are somewhere okay so as Julia
said earlier one of the main problems in
these communities is the existence of
poor ventilation and a lot of these
houses use wood burning which as you
know when wood burns it releases a lot
of toxins so our idea is we're mainly to
serve to move to smoke out of the house
or to clean the smoke as it leaves the
house so one of the ideas that we had
was the smoke dispenser which the way it
works is you the pot is put on the soap
so that I'm as the pot covers any any
way for the smoke to be released into
the house and instead it forces the
forces the smoke to go outward to
someplace outside of the house and we
also employ the use of these rings which
serve to accommodate different size of
different sizes of pots that they may
have and another idea that we had was
the smoke filter where the idea was as
the smoke rises over the stove it would
pass through possibly a wet towel in the
wet tile would clean the smoke as it
were as it would leave so a couple of
specs that we noted we're of course low
cost of course these places have low
income so they have to be affordable to
these people has to be easy to assemble
you don't want something that's going to
take six months to assemble so we
decided that it should take less than
two days to put together either prepare
it was very important in case any of
these things break down it should be
easy for these people to get parts to
repair their stove it should be
effective it should be able to increase
the air quality of the house by about
sixty percent it shouldn't interfere
with their cooking a lot of people
they like the space that they have on
their pasta that's what they're used to
which is why also in the this we made
the smoke filter so that it was able to
be stone away just for aesthetic
possible aesthetically pleasing to the
users should be easy to use obviously
these aren't things that these people
are used to using so it should be easy
for them to get used to using them and
it should be easy to maintain for
example with the filter shouldn't have
to be replaced for after every use we
estimated it may be about less than
three times a week a couple questions
that we had that would that will make us
more able to solve these problems is
what's the family's average income and
how much are they willing to pay out of
the average income for these stoves
we're in the house is still located and
is it movable and can we possibly put it
outside of the house what is already
being used in their homes to ventilate
what materials are in the area to are
available such as the metal and curtains
that could be used for the for our ideas
we also wanted to know how they store
their pots and pans and if we can
incorporate that into our ideas and we
also wanted to know what the house setup
was like in other windows are the
openings for a smoke outlet instead of
us having to break a hole in the wall
figure they may not like that Ben she's
not going to talk a little bit about the
charcoal stoves all right so a lot of
the ideas are very similar as we saw
they had sort of different features that
we thought would be useful to sort of
depending on what the preferences of
users were and so we sort of just
attacked it from a general standpoint of
like with the general shape of the joke
would be and what sort of a key feature
would be that we wanted to highlight and
so these are two of them one of the
first one is basically like that seals
Stephen lo sort of looks like a
vegetable steamer I don't know if you're
familiar though that they sort of open
and close they have like overlapping
layers and so it can it can face the
accommodate just like a variety of sizes
of pots and pans but it's still
maintained the seal all the way around
the pan assuming that is circular and so
that's sort of the idea and that's just
we don't have any specific designs for
that but you know you could incorporate
the airflow or the the insulation as
needed so we didn't really focus on the
specifics of it the second one that we
thought about was actually it's actually
very similar to the one that we saw back
there before we thought I mean it's a
funnel basically on that has a small
enough opening at the bottom and a steep
enough angle so that the charcoal gets
jammed with in the funnel uh is
something that happens all the time we
can get marbles
so this allows for airflow to come up
and fresh this to fall down but for the
larger pieces of charcoal to stay and so
we thought that that was just an
effective possible way of keeping the
charcoal in and having just a simpler
design and it also accommodates a
variety of cotton panel as it goes out
so the things that we wanted to make
sure and maintain or its effectiveness
as a stove that we wanted it to cook the
food just as well right like who would
want to switch to a stove that cook as
well as your other one so that one is
definitely number one and we want to
maintain its fuel efficiency not using
any more fuel than they do right now
because that also is there's no reason
to switch just oh that's less fuel
efficient and we also wanted to be
affordable so that it's so that you know
there's a reward for switching and also
pleasing pathetically and that
accommodates many pots and pans just so
that there any sort of barriers to
keeping people from using it so the
questions mostly revolved around what
currently exists in the places like we
said we don't really know much about our
partners there so it'll be looking
almost mostly be asking about materials
that are available like what they
usually use how they you what their
habits are in terms of cooking and you
know why they don't use charcoal or how
much they pay for fuels all these sort
of basic questions that really outlined
the needs of the community so I'm going
to be talking about improved lighting
and so we basically came up with two
general ideas that could be feasible
once again like we said we really don't
know a whole lot about what we're going
to be
all but this is something that they
recommended that we might look into we
don't know if this is feasible or not
but basically what we came up with was
the idea a first of white room which is
just going to essentially like what
sounds like we're just going to maximize
them gliding a vir like reflective
surfaces so we're thinking about like
receptors on the ceiling having white
curtains botany maybe a windows and
stuff and then painting the walls white
and color so that what light comes into
the room it makes the room look lighter
just in general because you know if you
have like dark colors on the walls makes
for s'mores the second idea we have is
this concept causes sunflower who is
kind of like it's sort of kind of like
an umbrella that can be used to direct
light in certain areas that you need um
go it can swivel and go up and down
based on where you want to direct your
light whether you wanted to eliminate
most of the room or if someone staying
up later than another person perhaps to
study or to prep for activities that
would take place during the song there
you don't want to interfere with anybody
sleeping or such so that is why we have
a direction and we have the week you can
adjust how how much lights directed base
by twirling it around and then also by
how much you open and expand it so some
project specs we came up with me one
obviously it'd be very flexible and to
have multiple uses so basically for
different tests that you might have
whether it's for
or for reading the ability to direct
your lights so where you can turn the
light that you choose to be directing we
want it to be affordable and reliable
and these are questions we don't
necessarily have a value for because we
don't know who we're working with so we
don't know what would necessarily be
reliable or more feasible and obviously
like the efficiency of like the quality
of why we want to be able to improve the
lighting that about fifty percent and
has as much brightness as we can so
obviously we're going to have to ask a
lot of questions such as the types of
light bulbs do they currently have
available how many light bulbs they
currently have available how much power
do they have access to how much light
does each customer need what type of
activities do they do would also
contribute to the type of lighting they
were in do they just need a little bit
of lighting for walking around such then
it doesn't have to be a sprite by third
reading and they're studying obviously
you're going to need a lot more direct
light and also how much are the customer
is willing to pay in also one of our
main ideas with the idea of a white firm
but are they going to even have access
to white and lighter color materials
obviously that's going to make that
entire design new if they don't so and
where is there a light bulb currently
located like is it wired into their
house that or is it more of a portable
nature and then do we need like direct
daylight and
dark spaces this was some of the
questions we were asked and so we have
some extended activities um so while
we're down in El Salvador we're going to
do a charcoal burn demo we're hoping to
at first demo to kind of group of people
that are more interested in this who
could learn to kind of be like our lives
on to the community so they would learn
firsthand and that kind of helped us
with a second demo to the larger
community and then we want to talk about
cooking indoors and I know what they're
actually doing if they're aware of these
dangers talk about charcoal usage and
how our charcoal burner would be
effective if they switch to charcoal
stones and then just discuss what they
use for lighting now and figure out how
we can improve on what they have so a
lot of it's just in the investigating
feel that learning about their living
habits
work with up to have now
what else yeah
help you
this is
so the idea was that it would have to be
replaced maybe less than three times a
week so like maybe every other day at
most and as far as cleanable I mean I
guess it could be cleanable if it's a
what's all but its needs still need to
look into letter yeah I mean we're not
filter experts and like the particulars
are really really small like that's what
makes a really gay
what I wouldn't necessarily take a lot
like tape lives very dangerous things
but we don't we don't know like what if
the whole thing
researchers
I would definitely like before proposing
that idea I wouldn't I wouldn't propose
an idea so that you don't actually know
if a wet towel will provide any
effective filtration so something you
look into is this feasible but I
wouldn't discuss it as an idea that has
merit to the people they were working
with until you know if it does and from
an experimental standpoint we have the
capability to run emissions tests in the
lab I don't know if we can pull off
running it before sunday but we might be
able to or certainly when you get back
you should definitely like it seems like
you are well prepared being prepared
just to be flexible and figuring out
what's going to happen I think you did a
great job given the lack of information
you had along those lines I I would try
calling the community partners today
like there's two that we have phone
numbers for so call them both that any
does anyone speak Spanish on the team
right so you could but you could help on
the phone today so that would be good to
start and then finally just stove
quality there's there was a lot of
designs there and some I think have more
merit than others and this is true for
group of Phoenix as well to think about
that you should definitely check out
those two links i put on the charcoal
lecture which is an organization called
aprovecha and then i think it's called
cook stoves not net because there's a
ton of cook stove designs out there some
of which are really great like the g CO
and others of which are getting sold and
do not actually improve efficiency or
emissions at all and it's really easy to
say my stove is better and get a website
up and get some funders without actually
doing any due diligence that your stove
is in fact better and so it's easy to
make a stove that's worse and you don't
want to be doing that
so cool let's like that thanks